today on the Matt wall show we have
exposed Vanderbilt's child mutilation
practices but now it's time to actually
do something about it I'll explain the
plan today also Stacy Abrams says that
the fetal heartbeat is a far-right
conspiracy the Pentagon is panicking
over their failed military recruitment
efforts and MSNBC host thinks he has the
ultimate gotcha on Ron DeSantis and our
daily cancellation The Washington Post
is the latest Outlet to claim that there
is a racist plot to keep black men out
of NFL coaching positions I'll explain
why those claims are completely wrong
and also stupid all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
the left has proclaimed an all-out war
on childhood having a will in place then
is the least you could do to protect
your kids it will gives you the power to
decide who will raise your kids should
something happen to you and your spouse
without one the state decides a will is
about protecting your legacy protecting
your finances ensuring that your medical
decisions are honored when you're able
to uh unable to see them through
deciding who will take on the
responsibility of raising your children
or caring for a parent or grandparent a
will may be your only opportunity to
directly to direct important family
heirlooms financial investments and
responsibilities to the proper people in
your life plus it's incredibly easy and
affordable with epic will epic will
bundles your last will living will
Health Care power of attorney hippo
release and durable Financial power of
attorney it only costs 119 for a single
person to create a will and when you use
promo code Walsh you'll save 10 so go to
epicwill.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package you want to do this right now
before it is too late that again is
epicwill.com promo code Welsh
welcome back to another exciting flannel
Friday you know my expose on
Vanderbilt's gender Clinic continues to
make major waves in a in a in a major
way on a national and local level even
as every effort is made on the other
side to lie deflect change the subject
or act like there's nothing here worth
talking about in the first place uh
Vanderbilt has the advantage of a
national and local media that knows its
role in a situation like this that is to
act as de facto PR representatives for
the institution for example our local
Nashville Public Radio published an
article written by a Shameless hack
named Blake farmer which says the
headline is this
Vanderbilt is the latest Target in a
far-right campaign against transgender
health clinics
that's the headline and this is
supposedly they position themselves as a
objective news Outlet the article itself
of course makes no specific mention of
any of the details I revealed in my
report except to say that I used
inflammatory language when describing
their practices
describing them accurately is
inflammatory meanwhile The Tennessean
which is another major local publication
tried to ignore the issue completely but
was eventually forced to acknowledge it
with this headline
Vanderbilt clarifies gender affirming
care policies amid conservative attacks
now National media hasn't been much
better The Daily Beast reported on the
situation with this framing Vanderbilt
Medical Clinic shuts down its website
after transphobic attacks
now the Washington Post was a little bit
more subtle with a fair headline social
media post Sparks calls to investigate
Tennessee's vumc which is fine then a
relatively even-handed report except
that the Post article like nearly every
other article written on the subject
from a non-conservative outlet does not
specifically mention the procedures that
the hospital performs on kids
the post says that I criticized
Vanderbilt for some of the quote
Services provided to minors but it does
not actually specify that those Services
include double mastectomies for 16 year
old girls irreversible hormone
treatments puberty blocking drugs that
are also used to chemically castrate sex
offenders
um the post will not include those
details because it knows that nearly
everyone who reads it will recoil in
revulsion and horror and say to
themselves you're telling me that's not
already illegal
I should also note here that the
progressive Christian Community in
Nashville otherwise known as you know
Heretics have taken a special interest
in this case and are rallying around the
hospital Matthew Paul Turner is a
Christian children's book author who
came out as gay a few years ago and then
left his wife and children and he
tweeted you're a terrible human Matt
Walsh
you make nothing better and one day your
sad little existence will reap what it
has sown over and over again
now that last part sounds almost like a
threat though uh I can't say I'm too
concerned but it is a little
disappointing in another way that that
you know again this is a children's book
author his name is also Matthew and
somehow we can't stick together
maybe he's just upset that my book sold
more in a week than probably his entire
catalog has sold in a lifetime but
anyway also uh Robin Henderson Espinoza
is a self-described activist Theologian
and clergy member who's Prof whose
preferred pronouns are I'm not making
this up
he they and doctor
so doctor has been listed as preferred
pronoun unironically
Robin tweeted this is white Christian
nationalist terrorizing children as a
trans person and clergy member I stand
with the underside of History not those
using the underside for their political
gain
I have no doubt that Robin is focused on
the underside I however am focused on
protecting children and protecting them
from horrific sexual and physical abuse
and medical experimentation
and in order to do that to really
protect them action
must be taken you know on the right we
have been historically I think pretty
good at identifying important issues and
raising awareness about them and that
needs to happen the the rareness the the
awareness raising the Consciousness
raising needs to happen it's important
because most people you know when it
comes to this issue
didn't know that this was happening to
kids and would have probably assumed
that it was already illegal
no change can be made culturally until
you reach a critical mass of people who
recognize that there is a problem and uh
and and that there is something that
must be changed and understand why it
must be changed so on the issue of
gender ideology we've been working to
build to that critical mass but what
happens when you get there
see this is where the right again
judging historically typically falters
because we tell every everyone that
something bad is happening and then lots
of people respond wow that's bad thanks
for telling me
and then we say well great talk folks
and we move on
the bad thing still fully intact
you know it's the bad things still
happening
so converting attention into action
that is where we fail
the left is very good at that
the right historically has been very bad
but not this time
we are going to do something about this
now I've already personally met with two
high-ranking members of the Tennessee
House and Senate
and we are working on a bill together
that would ban all gender transition
procedures for minors in the state no
drugs no surgeries
we are going to shut down Vanderbilt's
pediatric gender clinic and we're going
to make sure that no one else opens one
in this state ever again
we're also moving on the federal level
I've been in conversation with Senator
Marsha Blackburn who hosted a screening
of my film what is a woman a few weeks
ago and there were many local lawmakers
by the way who attended that screening
and I've been told personally that by
some of them that this movie has
motivated them to move against gender
ideology in the state I heard the same
thing from some of those politicians
that I hear from average people on the
street which is again I didn't know this
was happening you know or or I didn't
know it was this bad
now they know following our report on
Vanderbilt Marshall Blackburn has now
issued a letter to the FDA calling for
an investigation into puberty blockers
which have never been approved for use
on children in this way in fact the very
concept of a puberty blocker has never
been sufficiently studied or
investigated at all the drugs are used
off label for the purpose of blocking
puberty and there has been no effort in
the medical community to really
understand the long-term or even
short-term effects of this usage
so getting the FDA involved is an
important First Step I've also been in
communication with representative
Marjorie Taylor green who introduced a
bill weeks ago Banning child gender
transitions on the federal level
now right now no bill like that can
actually be passed into law of course
but it's important to have them on the
table anyway just as the FDA might right
now ignore Marcia Blackburn's demands
but it's important to make the demand
anyway and that's because we are forcing
this conversation we are making it an
issue
the midterms are a few weeks from now
we have made sexual indoctrination of
children and medical child abuse
enormous National issues in the lead-up
to the election
that is not an accident
back in January I tweeted that I was
planning an all-out assault on gender
ideology this year and that it would
begin with a project that would change
the conversation around the topic in
June we released what is a woman which I
think and hope fulfilled that promise
and is still fulfilling it
several weeks ago I pledged on this show
that we would take the momentum that we
built from that film and we would turn
it into a national movement that would
lead to tangible results and real action
and that is beginning right now
Tennessee is just the start
most importantly
we are fully on the offense now
okay we're we're not waiting around
for the left to tell us what topics we
should discuss or what positions we
should adopt
as the right has for so long operated
the left tells us the topics we're going
to talk about and then they also tell us
what position we're going to take but
you know we just take whatever the
opposite position of them is and then so
they are setting the terms
okay but we're not doing that now we are
not scrambling to take defensive
postures all the time as the left
dictates the terms of the argument
we are talking about things they don't
want to talk about
and we are fighting a battle that they
desperately don't want to have to fight
and are not prepared to fight
so this time we are the ones with the
plan of action and they are the ones
scrambling to respond
you could tell that they're not used to
being in that position
and they don't like it
and that's how it should be
because this is how we win
now let's get to five headlines
did you know that your home address is
part of the public record any cyber
Thief can use this one data point to
attempt various types of identity theft
crimes against You Bad actors can also
leverage this information to redirect
your mail without your authorization
they can try to scam you with official
looking letters requesting your personal
information it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day your
personal information gets exposed so
often that it's dangerously easy for a
cyber criminal to steal your identity
that's why protecting your identity can
be easy with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock
detects and alerts you to potential
identity threats that you may not spot
on your own like crimes committed by
thieves pretending to be you if you do
become a victim of identity theft God
forbid a dedicated us-based restoration
specialist will work to fix it for you
you know nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it's easy to help protect
yourself with LifeLock by Norton
Identity Theft Protection Starts Here
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com Walsh that's
lifelock.com Walsh for 25 off
uh there was one other of course there's
been a lot of leftist you know panicking
about this on Twitter but just this one
I thought was kind of funny uh this is
from a guy John
Aya darola
I guess he's a has something to do with
The Young Turks I don't know anyway he
he tweeted in response to you know when
I said we're gonna pass a law that makes
this illegal he says Matt Walsh has to
spend years of his life pretending he
gives an S about this all as a
distraction to help keep billionaire
taxes low what a weird effing way to
live
this again the reason I I read that to
you is because it shows you another
disadvantage
that the left has
they have a lot of advantages with all
the institutional power and everything
else in the media bias and all that
stuff but
um they also have a lot of disadvantages
some that we just talked about that you
know this is not a conversation they
want to have they're not prepared for it
but also the other disadvantage is that
they really don't understand us they
just don't they don't know they don't
understand
what we're doing they don't know who
they're dealing with or why
and that is an advantage for us that we
should exploit
ruthlessly
so you've got this guy and I and I
believe that he believes this I mean I
believe that he is this stupid and
utterly oblivious
and clueless that this is what he
believes and he's not alone
he says oh Matt he doesn't really care
about this if he cares about keeping
billionaire taxes low like why would I
care about that I I never talk about
cutting taxes for billion in fact I'm
I'm if I ever talk about cutting taxes
it's usually in the context of
complaining when Republicans focus on
that rather than these more important
cultural issues so
um I talk about the cultural issues
gender ideology Socialists use life
family issues all the time it's like the
only thing I focus on and uh and he has
decided that no that's all that is all I
don't even care about that that's all uh
this is all a smoke screen
because in reality I'm sitting around
every day just hoping that Jeff Bezos
gets a tax cuts
why in the world would I care about that
especially when all of the billionaires
are on your side they're all a bunch of
left all the all the most of the
wealthiest institutions and corporations
they're all on your side they're with
you
I don't like these people
but they don't unders they just they
don't get us they don't
and that is good
that's a good thing
it's why they're constantly being
blindsided it's why they're backed into
Corners that's why they're on their
heels right now because they just don't
get it
uh and I am I guess not going to say any
more to uh disabuse them of of their
false Notions because like I said it
works to our advantage yeah you're right
you're right John that's all I care
about um you know I wake up every day
saying to myself
I hope Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg
are making money today that's all I
think about I'm sitting around the
dinner table and it's all we talk about
it's I I live my entire life
fighting for that
and everything my entire public career
has just it's been one long uh you know
it's like I'm working undercover that's
all it is you've you've blown my cover
all right uh this one's daily wire says
Georgia Democrat Stacey Abrams said in a
recently service video that at six weeks
unborn babies heartbeats aren't real but
are a manufactured sound design a rather
a manufactured sound designed to take
away women's rights
Abrams is again campaigning to be the
governor of Georgia after a failed run
in 2018. notably the Democrat refused to
traditionally concede the race to
Republican Governor Brian Kemp
suggesting voter suppression and a
broken system
um so we have that clip and let's brief
clip let's listen to it
that is
one of the most deranged conspiracy
theories I've ever heard in my life
not only so there's no heartbeat it's
manufactured and it is specifically
manufactured so I guess when you go in
for the ultrasound the ultrasound tech
is part of a wide-ranging far-right
conspiracy
to convince you that babies are people
when really they are this is all a
conspiracy and the and the ultrasound
text they're in on it they're all a
bunch of Nazis and far-right extremists
terrorists
Glenn Kessler is a fact checker for the
Washington Post he came to Stacy's
defense of course says for what it's
worth
fetal heartbeat is a misnomer the
ultrasound picks up electrical activity
generated by an embryo the so-called
heartbeat sound that you hear is created
by the ultrasound not not until 10 weeks
can the opening and closing of cardiac
valves be detected by a Doppler machine
now look I'm tempted to just say
um just like I would say to John okay
you want to go in and believe that we're
that all we care about is tax cuts for
billionaires that's fine and here I'm
tempted to say okay fine if you guys
want to go out there and make the
argument that uh well it's okay to kill
the baby because the heartbeat isn't
technically a heartbeat
the heartbeat is it's a it's all part of
a cons
the fetal the fetal heartbeat is a
right-wing conspiracy if you want that
to be your argument especially going
into the midterms then go for it put it
on a bumper sticker I I encourage you
put it on poster boards put it on signs
March down the street fetal heartbeat is
a right-wing conspiracy
go ahead
um if you want to parse the definition
of heartbeat in order to justify
destroying human life
if you want to expose yourself in that
way
then go ahead
I stipulate if you want to expose
yourself in that way I don't mean in
like a Jeffrey tubing kind of way but we
should note here even so that they're
wrong so to fact check the fact Checker
back to the Daily wire article it says a
peer-reviewed science has found the
following the non-profit Charlotte
Lozier Institute has outlined quote
um
the heart the heart is actively beating
at six weeks between a conception and
birth the baby's heart will beat
approximately 54 million times
the baby's average heartbeat is uh 98
BPM this will rise to 175 BPM by nine
weeks gestation the presence of a
heartbeat at six to eight weeks
gestation correlates with a live birth
rate of 98 in normal pregnancies without
intervention
the brain has divided into three primary
sections responsible for sensing and
decision making moving and tracking
objects and vital bodily functions eyes
ears and nose start forming so that's
all that's happening at six weeks also
by the way we should note that um even
on planned parenthood's website up until
just now they also acknowledge that the
heartbeat starts at six weeks
interestingly enough now after this went
viral Stacey Abrams they changed it to
make their even though it had been there
for years they changed it to put it more
in line with what Stacy Abrams said
so there is a heartbeat of six weeks
but think about the wording
going back to uh Glenn Kessler think
about the wording
he says the heartbeat is six weeks he
says is really just electrical activity
by the embryo that's all it's electrical
activity generated by an embryo
well he's right of course
but then you could say that about the
heartbeat at any age
okay we could say that about Glenn
Kessler's heartbeat that's just
electrical activity being generated by
the body you could reduce any human at
any age
down to Mere mechanical functions if you
want
that can Glenn Kessel he's just a
skeleton covered with organs and muscle
and skin walking around
that's all he is
I mean you really you get into he's just
like a he's a bag of bones and flesh
walking that's all he is
Glenn Kessler he's a he's a collection
of atoms that's all he is
you care that much about one little atom
so you take one little one little tiny
atom and we don't care about that and
then you add a bunch of them and make
Glenn Kessler and suddenly he matters
you can use that language to dehuman uh
D person anyone
but it is strange it's strange how
selective the left and the media can
tend to be
on on this subject when exactly uh
in in what scenarios are we
acknowledging the personhood and
Humanity of unborn children so here's a
report the exact same day this is going
on The Today Show has a report
which also has to deal with you know
those quote fetuses that just generate
electricity that's all they do well
let's look let's watch this
wait so you guys have to see this have
you heard about this so this morning we
wanted to show you I'm trying to change
the subject some amazing baby faces look
at this so researchers in Britain wanted
to know if babies in the womb react when
the mom ingests the flavor of food and
this is what they saw do you want to
guess what was on the left
so the left is a baby in its resting
state and then on the right you see how
he smiles 20 minutes the mom made some
carrots oh on the left would be there
was just a resting seat that was
arresting but he liked the carrots she
had like a carrot pill so were there
other Foods yes there were other Foods
I'm glad you asked you want to look at
this Baby's reaction before that mom had
kale wow wow so here's the thing what
about if Mama had ice cream I don't know
why why would they go why would they go
with Let Me Explain the vegetables so
the seti's co-author says the images
could just show muscle movements when a
baby's reacting to maybe a flavor that's
bitter so you shouldn't interpret it
whether you know it's happy or distaste
no I think that's how I do yeah because
once they get out of the womb it's that
same one yeah it's the same way yeah
but it just goes to show you know what
you ingest yeah you are what you eat and
the 3D imagery is pretty cool they
didn't have that when I was pregnant no
did you get three yeah I got 3D honestly
Ollie and Rusty look exactly like they
do 3D images
my kids had chalk drawings
[Laughter]
every single person up there on camera
all four of them
would adamantly support so-called
abortion rights
so when it comes to babies experiencing
taste from the food that their mother is
eating
when it comes to that it's all they're
cute look at those little babies
but if we're talking about actually
executing those same babies in the womb
then they're just
collection of cells a clump of cells is
all
let me ask you something if a baby can
react to Brussels sprouts and kale
in the womb
uh do you think that the child might
react to being physically tortured and
torn apart limb from limp
might there be a reaction to that
if the baby can experience sensation
taste
what's the experience of um
being being
torn apart dismembered while you're
still alive
which is how they perform these
abortions especially the later stages
3D technology is also it's I mean it's
almost miraculous it's incredible
but that only goes to show how on the
conservative side of the pro-life side
uh we line up with science
okay we are the pro science side because
science
only continues ever more to vindicate
our position
you know the more the more we learn
about what is happening in the womb you
know the more we learn about human
development
the more horrific and barbaric abortion
becomes
um okay one of the things back because I
have to play this for you too speaking
of the abortion issue
I want you to watch this ad that's a Tim
Ryan posted on his Twitter account
and he's very proud of this ad but why
don't you watch this
hi my name is Nick Brown I'm a resident
of will be Ohio
I've lived in Ohio all my life I'm also
an army veteran I was active duty for
four years and I'm currently a Reserve
officer in the Jag Corps uh
this race to me is one of the most
important races in America today this is
a race that
is going to change a lot of lives we've
seen
what happened recently with Roe
and it's going to take legislative
action to be able to change something to
do that
and
I have two daughters
and it's incredible to me
how much their lives changed
and the last two weeks
sorry I'm getting emotional right now
my wife
is going to be working on this campaign
she's never done it before
this is not the America
Tim Ryan
is the opportunity
so this is a man and I use that term
only in the biological sense in this
case this is a man who
is crying it's getting emotional at the
thought that his daughters won't be able
to to abort his grandchildren
so he is emotional he's distraught
he's got young daughters and he's
already thinking about
the future he wants for them and uh and
he wants to make sure they can have
abortion so he's already thinking about
his young daughter's abortions
and uh and and he's very upset
that his own
progeny his own descendants his own
grandchildren will not be able to be
killed potentially
foreign
yet again if if this is the foot that
the Democrats want to put forward then I
say go for it
all right follow along with this story
this is from MSN
headline
Pentagon bedeviled by recruitment
failures as Solutions prove elusive
I'm always in favor of any headline that
can use a word like bedeviled but it
says the Pentagon has characterized the
headwinds in Stark terms saying its
recruitment environment is the worst
it's been since the end of the Vietnam
War some of the military services will
just barely meet their goals as the
fiscal year ends later this month the
Army the Armed Forces largest branch
will miss its Target by 30 000 soldiers
said Senator Kristen Kirsten gillibrand
Senator Tom Tillis said that there is
little evidence to suggest the Outlook
it will improve anytime soon adding
bleakly
there is no sunlight on the horizon
military leaders teach a three-word
mantra adapt and overcome to every
service member it's part reminder a part
roadmap for how to meet challenges head
on during the testimony military
officials offered a Litany of reasons
why factors outside of their control
undermine recruitment efforts with vague
promises to consider potential Solutions
and problems raised by the committee
um
and then it goes on with more of the
problems I face only one in 11 people
ages 17 to 24 have a propensity to serve
said Lieutenant General Caroline Miller
Senior Air Force personnel official
uh the and
they list some of the other problems
leading to this Americans are obese
competitive job market all the rest of
it okay so that's the problem
they can't recruit anyone and that is a
problem if you can't get recruits for
the military that's a problem but listen
to how MSN Begins the article okay
because I skipped the first paragraph
it says military officials and lawmakers
on Wednesday painted a grim picture of
recruiting efforts within defense
department as a recent study suggests
worry some shortfalls could grow worse
if more women declined to serve over
restrictive abortion laws in many
republican-led states where U.S
Personnel are based
oh so there you go so yeah there's a
problem with recruitment
but it's because women don't want to
serve in states where they can't get
abortions
so that that's why we're not getting
enough people to serve is because there
aren't enough abortions happening that
explains it so it's not like the woke
messaging and recruiting ads that are
chasing people away uh in fact chasing
away all of the sorts of people you
actually want and need in the military
making them head for the hills it's not
that it's not political correctness and
leftist indoctrination driving people
away it's not vax mandates and other
tyrannies inflicted on on our service
members it's not that people
fundamentally don't trust the government
and don't want to be sent overseas to
fight Wars that have nothing to do with
us
it's not any of that
it's that women can't get abortions
that's why there's a recruitment problem
right
okay next we have many Hassan on MSNBC
and he has some thoughts about DeSantis
and immigration and uh we'll play this
is kind of a long Global play some of
this go ahead
I want to tell you the story of Luigi
Colucci back during the first world war
she was stuck alone in Italy with her
teen daughters but the Homeland had
become too dangerous so in 1917 they
boarded a ship to America where her
husband and son had already settled for
work years earlier on that trip German
U-boats were just one of the hazards
they faced while Luigi and her girls
were still at Sea America which had
already allowed in thousands of
Europeans passed the xenophobic alien
act it banned migrants from Asian
countries as well as immigrants who
couldn't read that was a problem for
Louisa passenger records show that she
and her daughters were illiterate but
Luigi was lucky the alien act would not
take effect until that may she and her
children were put on a train to be
reunited with Luigi's husband and son
Luigi lived for four more decades as an
American with a great big American
family it's a story that millions of
immigrants to America can tell because
despite all the anti-immigration
sentiment back then and America had
pretty open borders compared with today
it didn't even have a militarized border
patrol yet and migrants like Luigi
Colucci didn't have to worry about being
put on a plane under false pretenses and
shipped thousands of miles away for an
anti-immigration stunt of course that's
what Florida Governor Ron DeSantis did
to about 50 mostly Venezuelan migrants
who were tricked into boarding a plane
in Texas that dumped them on Martha's
Vineyard the sheriff of Bear County
Texas where those migrants were picked
up off the street is now investigating
the case as a possible crime what
DeSantis did what he and conservatives
are bragging about
was gross inhuman cold-hearted and it's
even worse when you think of Luigi
Colucci trying to get into America over
a hundred years ago because you see
Luigi Colucci is Ron desantis's maternal
great great grandmother okay I was
waiting for the the M Night Shyamalan
twist at the end
Quran you tell me a guy with a last name
DeSantis has uh an immigrant in his
family
shocking my God this changes everything
I thought the Santa's family had always
been here I thought it was a name like
DeSantis he was a you know I thought he
was a Native American by ancestry
these people are so stupid
this guy in particular I don't know much
about it but I've seen a few clips of
him
he's always so proud of himself you can
tell he thinks okay the gap between how
he perceives his own IQ and what it
actually is is vast it's it's big enough
to fit a whole other IQ in between it
um and so he thinks this is a big gotcha
moment
and it isn't okay let me let me explain
why first of all
it it's very interesting that on the
left when it comes to so many other
issues climate change abortion
in particular uh they are very quick
to bring up the you know the myth of
overpopulation
right
there's too many people on earth like
but it's full or the art the entire and
they say now overpopulation is a myth
when we relate it to the entire world
okay we're not we're not anywhere near
the carrying capacity of the globe we're
not anywhere close to that I mean you
could still take every single person on
Earth and fit them like in Texas and in
fact they would you know everyone could
live in a townhouse and have a little
you know you wouldn't have a lot of room
you have a little postage stamp size
room uh maybe I don't know you have a
tenth of an acre or something and you
could do that okay that's how much room
there is
on the planet Earth and there is a vast
vast vast swaths of land that are empty
and I'm not just talking about
Antarctica where nobody can live I'm
talking about places that people could
live
um
fruitful lands are are still available
that we're not so the problem is that we
with overpopulation and the way we get
this misperception of our population is
that we all choose to live in like
bunched up communities which is why
whenever you read about of our
population they always show pictures of
uh Tokyo or New York or something with
people all crammed in walking on the
sidewalk they don't show you vast rural
areas uh they don't include that now all
that being said
it's still interesting to me
that if you if you imagine that there is
an overpopulation problem with too many
people on earth then already how can you
draw a comparison between immigrants
from a hundred years ago 200 years ago
to immigrants today because by your own
admission there's just like too many
people
that's one big difference
so that's a that's that's a difference
or an argument that should resonate with
them as Believers in overpopulation
um but let me say what the actual
difference is it's not really about the
number of people in America I mean there
are a lot more people today than there
were when uh
when desantis's great great grandmother
came here
I still wouldn't say that we're at
carrying capacity exactly
what the difference though it's about
the systems that are in place
Okay so
when immigrants came to this country
a hundred years ago
they were still now the land was was
fully settled back in the 1920s
but they were still in a large way
helping to build the country
they were they were coming and
immediately helping to build it
this is this is this is the case 100
years ago it's especially the case when
you go back farther than that because
the other thing we hear from guys like
media sun is that we're all we're all
immigrants we're all descended from
immigrants right
and so they'll take him even if your
family came here 200 years ago 250 years
ago
500 years ago you're not off the hook
yeah but again these were and it's it's
more and more the case the farther you
go back
these were people coming and helping to
build the country
with a country that was not built the
way it is today and they were coming to
help build it they were they were coming
legally another important distinction
they were coming legally and if you want
to say it's because the laws were
different or our approach to immigration
was different fine they were coming
legally though
already a definitional difference
between that and illegal immigrants of
today who are sneaking across the border
but it's not just that they were coming
legally to help build a country if
somebody came here 200 years ago many of
many of the immigrants who came say 200
years ago they came and they were the
ones who went out west okay they went
out onto the frontier a lot of them died
in the process
um what about today
well the country is fully built now all
the systems are in place and so now when
illegal immigrants come or even you know
not even legal immigrants they are
coming to take advantage of systems that
are already in place
and when we talk about systems primarily
I'm talking about the welfare system the
welfare so we have a massive
trillion dollar multi-trillion dollar
welfare state that these people are
coming and they are taking advantage of
uh and it's not sustainable it becomes
an enormous and has been and is now an
enormous strain and drain on our country
when
Rhonda Sanchez's great great grandmother
came here
uh those systems were not in place like
they are now
so did you have immigrants on one hand
from 100 years ago 200 years ago 250
years ago were coming to build a country
as opposed to now where they're coming
to take advantage of what the country
has already built
big difference
and if anyone can't see the difference
I'm not sure what else I can do to
explain it other than just say what it
is if you can't connect the dots there
I'm not sure what to tell you
all right
let's see what else do we got here
I was slightly interested in this only
mildly so maybe we'll play a little bit
of this clip
uh some celebrity gossip from the daily
wire it says hyper woke Maroon 5
frontman Adam Levine cheated on his
Victoria's Secret model wife bahati
Prinsloo with Instagram model Sumner
Stroh and tried to name his child with
princelu after the mistress
so this is one of these things that's
been in my peripheral just so you go on
you go on social media and there are
people talking about Adam Levine and I
guess screenshots of text messages that
he had sent his Mistresses but anyway
what interested me more about it is this
act the mistress herself what's her name
again Sumner Stroh who's an Instagram
model
and she blew the Lido off of the on this
Scandal and
you know put out a video on tick tock
making herself into the victim of an
affair that she participated in
let's play a little bit of this
they're retaking this like 10 times now
essentially
I was having an affair with a man who's
married to a Victoria's Secret model at
the time you know I was
young I was naive and I mean quite
frankly I feel exploited I wasn't in the
scene like I am now
um so I was definitely very easily
manipulated
we're in five is practically elevator
music at this point so I'm sure you know
who Adam Levine is
um but Adam and I were seeing each other
for about a year
after I stopped talking to him over you
know a period of months this is uh how
he came back into my life
he said okay serious question I'm having
another baby and if it's a boy I really
uh want to name it Sumner you okay with
that dead serious
right I don't care about this uh fine
here's my only point about this so Adam
Levine is cheating on his wife and he's
a celebrity you know uh musician and
he's a scumbag and he's betraying his
wife and his family
no big no big no breaking news there
okay I think that's not a big surprise
uh that's bad it's not a big surprise
what I what I'm looking at though is
that like this this and and we've seen
other examples of it even recently
with women
who were
involved in sexual relationships with
with men as adults so they're adults who
got into consensual sexual relationships
with with men and then after the fact
claiming they were groomed
and exploited
you're you're a grown-up you you made a
choice to be involved and now you're
you're one of the victims you're with a
married man now okay he's scumbag number
one here I don't deny that at all
because he's the one who made a pledge
he made a commitment to his wife and
he's betraying her so he's come back
number one but you're scumbag number two
okay and it's it's a pretty close second
because it does as I say it does take
two to tango in this case and or however
many people may have been involved in
any particular episode
um
you chose to be there and now you're
saying you were groomed as a grown-up
so this is this backwards topsy-turvy
world we live in where we can't talk
about children being groomed
so the idea of children being groomed is
they tell us non-existent it's not
happening we can't even talk about it
in fact if you even talk about it on
Twitter they'll ban you
so no children aren't being groomed
that's not a problem but grown adults
Instagram models are being groomed by
the rock stars they're choosing to have
sex with
there was another there's another
musician recently I think it was the
arcade fire guy I'm pretty sure
had his own sort of sex scandal where he
was involved with grown-ups who were
claiming that they were groomed and
exploited
but again you can't not not with the
kids the kids that's not a problem we're
not talking about that
so kids being taken to
drag shows
or kindergartners being taught about
gender identity and sexuality that's not
grooming
but a rock star hitting on some
Instagram model bimbo who's an adult
that is grooming
finally from the New York Post I hate to
say I told you so but here it is
a Tasmanian woman has shared her
incredible find on the sand at Bruni
Island mistaking and almost completely
transparent fish for a piece of seaweed
we'll put a picture up on the screen
uh it says that this is this is a
transparent fish
apparently they hatch out in the ocean
and they're initially part of the
Plankton they're actually they're a
species of eel and they're totally
transparent you can like see right
through them
so I told you you see that picture there
that's what Ariel should look like
scientifically speaking
I couldn't call this any better we just
had the translucent fish discourse
less than a week ago and now we have
this discovery of uh it's transparent
not translucent but still
so there you go
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
s
with the ever increasing numbers of
makes and models of cars it's impossible
for a traditional chain storefront to
stock all the parts you need why wait
for the man at the counter uh to order
parts for your car from the brand that
his warehouse warehouse happens to carry
you have a computer in your pocket it's
called your cell phone which can go on
the internet if you didn't know that
just go to rockauto.com and you're going
to find everything you need rockauto.com
has been in the auto parts business for
20 years family owned their goal is to
make Auto Parts available and affordable
to keep you safe on the road they not
only have the auto parts you need but
they will give you a selection of
trusted Brands and name brands that you
can choose from the rockauto.com catalog
is very easy to navigate you can quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer
chain stores have different price tiers
for professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers but rockauto.com uh
they don't play that game prices are the
same for everybody and they're reliably
low for everybody amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need go to rockauto.com
get brakes shocks carpets wipers
headlights mirrors Mufflers lug nuts or
any other part that you might need
rockauto.com and be sure to write Walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that I sent you to
rockauto.com
uh Judith says only people like you Matt
can possibly rescue our country please
don't become weary in well-doing well
not to sound corny but it's not people
like me it's People Like Us Judith and I
actually do mean that it's uh obviously
I'm very far even here at the daily wire
I'm very far from a one-man band we have
a whole team
um and everyone here on the team does
great work but but even beyond that like
you know it's we also need our our
members and our supporters
uh we couldn't do it any of this without
them and then there are people outside
the deal why are they doing doing uh
great work as well okay Bobby Frost says
you're in Candace's comments about porn
last night were spot on so this is two
nights ago at the backstage my hubby and
I were a little surprised at the other's
response is we've been married 22 years
and together 25 years I've never watched
porn together or alone since since being
together we both had minimal exposure to
it before we were together it always
felt wrong and not in a sexy way to be
watching others engaging in sex acts we
have a healthy and active love life and
neither of us have ever stepped out so
porn is not a given or a necessity
relationship tremend you all for saying
that and sticking to it
um thank you from the housewife that
would feel betrayed if my husband was
upstairs watching porn while I feed the
kid and you should feel betrayed because
it is in fact a betrayal
uh
s says I saw someone just yesterday
claiming to be a security guard for that
hospital who posted on Reddit calling
you a doxing terrorist for literally
just showing videos the hospital itself
made public absolutely amazing yeah
doxing is
when you find private information
and first of all let's let's also
stipulate the doxing is something that
happens against a an individual a person
I'm not exactly sure how you docs an
institution
but uh doxing we talk about docs at
least in a negative way it's a private
individual you're releasing private
information about them because you want
to embarrass them or get them hurt or
oftentimes both
in this in this case we are taking
resources that they themselves have made
and have provided to the public and
we're saying hey guys look at this stuff
um
PATCO says I don't look at it as a
membership I look at it as a donation to
a cause I believe in thank you
well I appreciate that but you should
look at it as a membership because it's
actually not a donation you know this is
we're not a non-profit charity begging
for donations we are a business and part
of the deal here is that uh yeah if you
are a daily wire member you're taking
part you're part of something important
part of a movement
but you're also getting something in
return for your money we're not asking
for uh you know we're we're not we're
not a charity case
and that's that is one approach I mean
there are a lot of uh non-profits out
there conservative nonprofits and some
of them do good work but they are in the
position of sort of always being a
charity case of having to solicit
donations like just give us your money
and then we'll promise down the line to
do something worthwhile with it uh this
is different this is a business
transaction and we want to keep it that
way
um
and
MN 32 says hi Matt aside from the daily
wire what other news sources do you like
and Trust well aside from us uh the
post-millennial you hear about a lot of
new sources you hear me read from a lot
on the show The post-millennial they do
great great work also there's a site
called Redux that I mention often on the
show they're a feminist kind of
anti-gender ideology news site I imagine
that the people who run it would
probably hate my guts I don't know that
for a fact but the people in that group
I generally do based on my experience
but they still even so however they feel
about me I appreciate their work there
are a lot of other outlets too you know
and then also individuals
um I mean obviously you know that I I
harvest material from Libs of tick tock
all the time she remains as I've said
for months one of the most important
journalists working in America today
same for Chris Ruffo who you hear me
mention often Jack besobic too seems to
always have great Scoops so there are
um
there are people who as I said and what
what all of us are doing is we're trying
to
and in many ways we're doing a favor for
as we go into the midterms for
Republican politicians
okay we've made these things part of the
conversation and we're trying to hand
you the reins guys so take the reins
all the way to Victory finally this is a
Twitter DM Beth says Matt I usually
agree with you but your comments about
picky eaters really just shows me that
this is a parenting problem you've never
dealt with you're lucky but don't judge
other parents please yes this was
someone on Twitter yesterday who uh I
think it was a some kind of a parenting
advice columnist I think
who said that
you know she's tired of parents
who say of their children oh well the
kids just eat whatever we eat
and a lot of people were retweeting that
and agreement with that and say oh
that's not realistic that's not how
people and I only respond to that saying
how well what other Arrangement could
you possibly have are you are you people
really sitting down for dinner every
night and making a separate meal for
your kids is that what people really do
uh no we don't do that and we also don't
have picky eaters in our house and I'm
sorry I do think now I know it might be
more difficult with some kids than it is
with others my son my older son for
example has always been like a garbage
disposal you just you'll eat anything
so you can get you can get lucky in that
way but I do think that parents are
complain oh my kids are piggy won't eat
anything so we have to make a separate
meal for our kid and I've been to many
houses where they're eating dinner and
the kid has their own you know
everyone's eating a real meal the kid
has just like chicken nuggets and uh
Kraft macaroni and cheese or whatever
and sometimes you're going to do that
sometimes you're going to have quick
dinners and that's fine but generally
picky eaters that is a product of
conditioning and first world luxury
so I would say that if your child is a
picky eater it's because you are
allowing your child to be because you've
made that an option
if you go to a third world country there
are no picky eaters
and so how do you get past having a
child's a picky well you
give them the food you say this is what
we're eating for dinner
if they won't eat it then you say okay
we're gonna go hungry tonight and it's
only going to take a few times of that
of them being hungry before they'll
start to actually eat the food that's
provided to they're not going to starve
themselves they're not going to
literally just say okay I'll starve to
death
eventually they'll eat if they're hungry
enough
well this is exciting tonight you can
see a brand new series on daily wire
plus called breakaways with Allison
Williams if you don't know the story
Allison was a successful ESPN sideline
reporter but when ESPN made the vaccine
mandatory for all employees she refused
to get it for a very valid reason she
was trying to get pregnant and was
worried about potential side effects
rather than take the risk she quit on
breakaways Allison sits down with
athletes who took a stand for their
beliefs the first four episodes featured
Jonathan Isaac Nick rolovich Ennis
cancer freedom and Dana White those
episodes will be available tonight at 7
pm Eastern and four more episodes are
coming soon head to dailywireplus.com
right now to become a member and watch
the series tonight now let's get to our
daily cancellation
foreign
ly in the mood to discuss anything
related to football as I'm currently in
the process of losing badly in our daily
wire fantasy football league if this
continues I'll eventually be doomed to
suffer the agreed upon punishment which
is a courtside seats at a WNBA game the
very thought fills me with grief and an
intense sense of dread though behind
both of those feelings is also I admit a
hint of excitement about what an
incredible trolling opportunity that
would be so it's a confusing mix of
emotions and
doesn't put me in the right frame of
mind to discuss any football related
topic
but the Washington Post today has left
me no choice so wapo is is out this week
with a report titled how the NFL blocks
black coaches nearly two decades after
the NFL enacted the Rooney Rule teams
hiring and firing practices still
disadvantaged black coaches at every
turn and it's getting worse a
post-investigation found now this is
nothing to do of course every year
around this time as the NFL season ramps
up we get a new flurry of moral panic
and media hand-wringing over the alleged
conspiracy to keep black people out of
head coaching positions in the NFL and
every year there are new reports in
every report simply in more words than
is necessary restates the fact that
there are more white coaches than black
in the NFL and then follows that data
point with a whole string of wholly
unsupported and absurdly irrational
assumptions about why this disparity
exists
as the post says in its headline the NFL
is blocking black coaches
but they have no evidence of black
coaches being blocked they have only
evidence of black coaches being fewer in
number than white coaches
this in itself does not prove or even
realistically indicate a racist
conspiracy I could just as well point to
all the people that are astronauts and
observe the data point that I am not an
astronaut and thereby and thereby
conclude that there's a deliberate
conspiracy to prevent me specifically
from being an astronaut
there's a conspiracy to stop me from
being an astronaut well how do you know
that because I'm not an astronaut
this is what passes for critical
thinking among our media Elite
but this time around they've also
enlisted current and former black
coaches to help make the victim case so
let's take a look at that
what everyone is looking for
and then head football coach all right
this is what it's supposed to look like
what I couldn't accept though was that
okay I'm black and we're not supposed to
get opportunities so this is just how
it's going to be Levy I couldn't accept
that
[Music]
I was in this business to teach guys to
be the best football player they could
be in my era we played but you didn't
see a lot of African-American coaches so
it wasn't you know your your path or
your thought process I love playing the
game and when I was done I was going to
coach I felt compelled to give back
I knew if I had success that that would
open the door for people and I kind of
realized it was like a network of black
coaches
trying to help younger coaches like get
in but you always kind of feel you know
that way you have the responsibility to
do this the right way because there's
many people who were career-long NFL
assistants who never got that
opportunity I think we got to do a
better job with ourselves to put
ourselves in better position to make
guys like Tony proud to make guys like
her and proud there's only 32 jobs in
this league so whether you get a second
chance or not you're lucky no matter
what color you are
I do think the words genius
Guru
quarterback Whisperer are all phrases
that they use to describe
non-african-american coaches it's as if
we don't have the same IQ intelligence
level as some of our other brothers you
can go out and catch the ball you can
throw the ball
but can you can you lead
now let's make a few points here first
the guy at the end of that clip is Romeo
Cornell he's a black man who had a long
career as an NFL coach before retiring a
couple of years ago in his 70s the first
guy in the clip is Lovie Smith he's a
current black NFL coach who has also had
a long career now Smith is a picture of
mediocrity with a career win loss record
of almost exactly 500 he's lost as many
games as he's one as a head coach and
yet he's still a coach and was just
hired by a new team this year in spite
of the fact that during his previous two
seasons as a coach with a different team
he finished with a total of eight wins
and 24 losses combined
as for Romeo Cornell he coached three
different teams over the course of 15
years and finished with a combined
record of 32 and 63. so mediocre would
be a high compliment in his case in fact
of all the black coaches featured in the
video only one Tony Dungy is or was
successful for my win-loss perspective
all the rest range from terrible to
average Hugh Jackson also featured
survived for 40 games as the head coach
of the Browns and one get this three of
them he won three games out of 40. and
only at that point did he finally get
fired what's my point
my point is simply that if there's a
conspiracy to keep black men out of head
coaching positions it doesn't make any
sense that so many mediocre and even
downright awful black coaches could have
such a long and somehow still lauded
careers
now there are a lot of white NFL head
coaches who also are terrible or
mediocre and manage to just hang around
and it's very confusing and it's like
frustrating for the fans so this happens
with white coaches and black coaches but
my point is that if there's a conspiracy
the theory of an anti-black conspiracy
in NFL coaching does not predict
that there will be an army of bad black
coaches who still get and keep those
jobs
and when you have a theory that does not
predict what You observe in reality it
means the theory is wrong that's how you
test a theory
but there's more as is often rightly
pointed out in these discussions the NFL
suffers from enormous racial disparities
in other places as well for example
almost every cornerback in the league is
black almost every safety watt
linebacker wide receiver is black if
racial disparities on the sidelines are
evidence of racism then racial
disparities on the field should also be
evidence of racism of course the race
hustles will try to flip this around you
know they'll acknowledge that there are
many more black people than white
playing football but then they'll
declare that this is all the more reason
why there should be more black people
coaching but I could just as easily make
the argument the other way since there
are so many white people on the
sidelines there ought to be more white
people playing
so the left posits that black people are
condemned to make millions of dollars
playing the game rather than coaching it
but I might as just as well argue that
whites are condemned to make millions
coaching it rather than playing it
these disparities exist across the
league
but the the last explanation for the
disparity makes no sense and they could
easily be refuted by their own arguments
turned against them
so how do we actually explain it
well it's kind of an interesting
question like if you can get past the
racial stuff it's actually interesting
so let me present a hypothesis that has
the advantage of lining up with reality
and Common Sense
so many children grow up dreaming of
being in the NFL
very few of them I imagine dream of
being coaches that's not what kids are
you know out on the field like you find
kids out throwing footballs around and
everything else you don't find very many
that choose to have a whistle or uh you
know you know standing on the sideline
with a clipboard because they want to be
a coach
almost everyone who wants to be in the
football business wants to play
yet black people are more likely to
succeed on the field as the statistics
clearly show it's just a statistical
reality
which means that white people who cannot
make it as players but yet still love
the game are motivated to make the
transition into coaching sooner and in
greater numbers you'll note that many of
the greatest coaches currently in the
league and through the history of the
sport were mediocre players who became
legendary coaches they had a lot of
times they had short careers sometimes
they didn't even make it into the NFL or
if they did they were only there for a
few years and then they washed out
remember they became legendary coaches
in fact
being a mediocre player gave them an
advantage in coaching perhaps not just
because they got into it sooner but
because their lack of physical skill
even as players forced them to look at
the game differently and seek mental
advantages to compensate for their
physical disadvantages
this also explains why great players not
just in the NFL but in every sport are
and not just black but also white often
make very bad coaches
so it doesn't make any sense to say well
there are so many great black players
though why would there be more black
coaches it doesn't make any sense
because being a great player does does
not in any way automatically translate
into being a good coach if anything
history indicates that it's it's a
hindrance
Mike Singletary was featured in that
Washington Post video he was an abysmal
failure as a coach he was a terrible
coach
but he was a Hall of Famer as a
linebacker for the Chicago Bears many
such cases
as I said this holds true in other
sports Wayne Gretzky was not a good
hockey coach Michael Jordan isn't a
coach but he proved himself to be
totally inept as the owner of a
basketball team
and you find this trend in many other
fields outside of sports great salesmen
often make really bad sales managers
great scientists often make bad science
teachers
people who are experts at doing things
are often shockingly incompetent when it
comes to teaching other people how to do
those things why well I think part of it
is what I already theorized that those
who are in a certain field or profession
but are not gifted at actually
performing the tasks well by necessity
have to cultivate other skills in order
to remain in the field
but there's more to it than that I think
people who are
instinctively great at doing something
might in a sense be too close to the
skill to understand it abstractly so
teaching and coaching is all about
abstraction it doesn't matter if you can
do it all that matters is that you can
understand and can explain how it's done
actually if you're really great at
playing a sport or making a sale or
playing an instrument it means that you
are in the process of Performing the
skill doing lots of things unconsciously
yet the fact that they are unconscious
means that you will not necessarily be
equipped to explain them to someone else
much less teach them how to do it
you can probably find examples of this
in your own life and you know my case
much of my job revolves around public
speaking I speak in public in different
forums that all require different but
related skill sets giving a speech is
different from hosting a podcast which
is different from doing a three-minute
hit on a cable news show which is
different from publicly debating
somebody now I like to think I've had
some success in all of those areas but
could I teach a class on it probably not
I can do it I'm not sure if I could tell
you how to do it
so if I'm not hired as a public speaking
coach is that because the public
speaking world is conspiring against me
obviously not I've had a lot of success
in that world no it's just because
explaining a thing is not the same as
doing it and being good at one does not
mean you'll be good at the other
if anything it often means the opposite
so this is my theory to explain the
racial unbalances in NFL coaching I
think it makes sense it takes into
account statistical facts and realities
of human nature
um it's not insulting to anyone
and it makes predictions that uh can be
observed in reality
but it doesn't help anyone become a
victim
and that's why it will be of course
discarded
in favor of the racism claim as always
and that is all why
who's canceled today I guess the
Washington Post we'll just go with them
they are today canceled that'll do it
for this portion of the show as we move
over into the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you on Monday
happy Friday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]